okay so as you can see that was a study
project for my bachelors
Jesus I did it with my supervisor my
t-bird and service but he is not present
today what can I tell you more and I
started my master's degree now in
October and I will continue of the
project okay some agenda introduction
some motivation why the project a crane
was started then there's some procedure
about the technology used results
summary and bibliography ok let's start
ok so when it comes to aerial
photographs it's commonly used that it's
nowadays come on use of big data and
when it comes to solar panel
installations in Poland there is no
obligation to record it to any office so
basically you can install such a system
gain some energy and do not record it to
any office so we do have a problem with
the amount of panels in Poland because
when there is no need to record it we
don't know how many panels do we have as
we know the European Union so all the
countries and from the European Union
signed a paper in 2008 that so they said
that they will increase the number of
renewable energy to 20% also Poland did
it so it's going to be nice to have some
metrics about how many panels do we have
ok so yeah so one approach is just to
identify the panels from the space
without the knowledge of the yeah of the
people
okay so when it comes to the existing
knowledge about solar panels in Poland
we do have three main sources operators
so when you produce too much energy and
you would like to sell it you have to
contact your operator and then you can
sell the energy for 80% of of the price
so it's not worth it
general and yeah and they have all the
statistics so they know about the
installation power then it comes with
Central Statistics Office they create
every year I wrap a report it's named
energy from renewable resources but it's
summer it's a questionnaire II based on
a sample four and a half thousand so
yeah it's not reliable there's one
alternative it's PW monitor it's a
portal where you can like at your system
to the side so you see how many for
example solar panels are in Poland or in
the city but this is not obligatory okay
so when it comes to detecting panels I
found two projects the first one deep
solar it was conducted by the University
of Stanford they used Google Maps and
they carried out the analysis to the
whole state so the analyst analyzed
pretty a lot of pictures over 300,000
and at the end they had 90 percent of
accuracy pretty good and project from
European FF him from Europe and deep
Solaris from the Netherlands they did it
the same but they trained the model on
every city separate also more than 90
percent accuracy
okay about the procedure so when it
comes to data I didn't use Google Maps
we we found out that we can find better
data so when it comes to the data from
the gear pause it has some resolution 5
centimeters pan one paper one pixel and
I found that Google Maps has 15 meters
pan per 1 pixel so yeah it's a huge
difference and there was a right because
it's aerial photograph so there has to
be a plane that takes the pictures so it
was seven days in 2016 and after we sent
a paper we got over 100 gigabytes of
photo graphs and it was in TIFF format
and we also sent a paper for the layer
of buildings because that these were all
just images without the buildings of the
layers so we didn't knew where are the
buildings were a parking or where is a
church and when it comes to the spatial
data processing it was done in our so
it's also it's also possible to conduct
projects in two programming languages
yes an example how it looks so here's
the the building layer as you can see
it's red area and probably you see that
it's not perfect fitting so yeah that
was a problem what I'm gonna talk about
it later
yes so when it comes to the population I
analyzed just post nine so 42,000
buildings and I was searching for roofs
with solar panels
so when it comes to spatial data
processing
SSO the building layer was not perfectly
fitted to the images so we had to use
some buffer it was a half meter and at
the end we used just buildings from one
section because we got like Freehan
images and sometimes a building was in
two separate files so we didn't include
this because it would be hard to combine
and ended so at the end we just took
this 9300 buildings so here the
buildings without the space just the
roof yeah and you see that here is the
buffer up applied so we gained a little
bit more information but sometimes as
you can see it was still cut and yeah of
course here are some panels and as you
can see also that it's not always the
same angle of the panel sometimes it's
laying sometimes it has some degrees so
when when it comes to technologies used
the beginning I used chaos but I had
some issues because I used my university
technology infrastructure and we didn't
have any GPU so doing chaos without GPU
is pretty hard so I found this package
in Python it's an object detection
system which Apple acquired two years
ago for over 100 millions of dollars and
this package is based on on Yolo so you
only look once a deep learning framework
and at the end I used AWS because it
didn't make any sense to yeah your CPU
so when it comes to Yolo
engine behind to recreate this is how it
yeah
tracks and identifies the objects so
there's always a rectangle with a label
of the of the object and as you can see
direct it's possible that these layers
are laying under so how is you are
working and in general to recreate it
converts the image to a smaller one and
then it provides a grid 13 by 13 so this
is the first step then two roads here we
predict here the bounding box
predictions and here's the class
prediction and this does not mean that
here is a doc this does mean when there
is an object it's a dog so it's class
probability conditional class
probability and at the end we combine
this two like approaches and we get a
bounding box with a probability and the
class so it comes the loss function and
there's three parts a classification
loss localization loss or the error
between the predicted bounding box or
the predicted rectangle and rectangle
done manually and confidence loss okay
so I had to annotate the images and it
was a long process because I had to
annotate over 4,000 images so I used for
GG image & titers well-known annotator
and basically at the end I got a CSV
file with the with the photo name and
with coordinates
some results someone comes to results
yeah here's the training so don't look
at this basically yeah
training took over ten hours at AWS and
here's here are the results for the test
group and as you can see the motor has
some problems with basically it has some
problems with windows some windows just
look like panels so in most of the cases
the model predicts badly some windows it
says that it's a panel but it's not yeah
precision ninety-three percent will
trickle nearly one okay so now some
images so this is how it looks you
probably don't see that but here's also
probability so here was just 40 percent
of probably that it's a panel and here
is like in 98-89 so that's a correct one
is also a correct one but here is the
angle of the system a little bit
different but still predicted correctly
that was an uncertain because we didn't
know if it's a panel or just the window
it's sometimes just difficult for the
human eye to identify it yeah and some
not valid examples so yeah that's a roof
without any panel but distract the
structure of the roof yeah it looks like
like a panels of the model predicted
it's a panel what's not correct yeah
this one was not I recognized I don't
know why but maybe due to the fact that
it's a shadow here so also unrecognized
but it's probably to the fact that the
color of the roof is similar to the
panel so my the reason why it's not
recognized yeah we predicted them and we
took the model we took the old of the
images and we predicted and gives them
up of post nine with all the solar
systems yeah and as you can see there
are districts without panels here's some
huge residential blocks and it's nice to
see that basically it doesn't make sense
that in areas in the in the center of
Poznan there are no and solar panels
yeah it's correct because the roofs are
there's there's no space for some panels
but in the suburbs most of the cases
there are the most Paris summary so we
predicted and found 476 panels and we
ejected manually so it's the minimum
number of panels in Poznan and it's
about two percent of the buildings when
it comes to a project it was the first
in Poland and as you could see the
greater the the model has the biggest
problem with recognizing panels were and
they are not present but when there is a
panel it's gonna be predicted and found
and yeah as you can see the deep Solaris
project they had an issue with using the
model in other cities so probably we're
gonna have the same problem that the
model from Poznan will not be good and
for example Warsaw and that's an example
of a joint project in Arendt
title ok bibliography and that's all
thanks
[Applause]
questions yes what a version of viola do
you use to recreate is tiny Ola
okay so it's yellow for the second
version but it's with some secret they
write something like we use tiny Ola
with some modifications so at the end we
don't know basically the weights and
anything but that's a simple framework
to predict
did you tried something more
sophisticated like faster or CNN or
Moscow CNN no I just wanted to basically
I wanted to use a framework that is easy
fast and yeah as I said I conducted the
analysis and on Keros but it was hard to
train and I had to keep changing and
keep training and I didn't have time and
the resources so no I didn't use maybe
in the future and did you use no but I
couldn't find any good data sources I
was searching for some panels like a
data source but I couldn't find there is
there is a data source from the deep
solar project but it was bad resolution
because they took the images from Google
Maps and I had some other resolution but
yeah so I think that at the end it
wouldn't make any sense so I took the
time and found all the panels and then
annotated them thank you no more
questions
choice pika all right maybe comments
okay so thank you so much boy talk
Thanks and yeah pick up Lowe's
[Applause]